what is the biggest issue then that
feminism faces I think it's the mindset
women taking like the agency women
taking initiative I think it's mindset
holding them back a lot because if you
want to be in a competitive world and
compete you have to have the right
mindset and I think a lot of people
blame their lack of confidence or what
Society tells them for the reason that
they're not achieving what they need to
achieve when that's not the case you
have to have the mindset of achieving
because the men who built the world had
the mindset of building it so the women
who want to engage and build that
further they need to have that same
mindset